des écoles en plein nettoyage selon la
ville de schoelcher pas moins de
soixante personnes mobilisées services
extérieurs et personnellement grévistes
pour tout remettre en ordre
il s'agit de garantir l'accueil des
enfants lundi prochain dans de bonnes
conditions
exemple les salles des maternelles de
batelière
pour moi tout à fait plausible cette
place a nettoyé dont on commençait donc
il ya quand même du nettoyage
il ya de la poussière et après on est
resté quand même quinze jours permet une
reprise qui inquiète néanmoins de
nombreux parents deux heures de
pourparlers ce midi en mairie n'ont pas
suffi à rassurer tout le monde
la garderie de la crèche et la cantine
la réunion s'achève sans aucune
certitude
moi j'ai trois enfants dont l'aîné qu'à
l'école primaire ans madame elle qui à
l'école maternelle est le dernier qui
est donc on vois pas trop qui à la
crèche donc je ne sais pas quoi faire
parce qu'en septembre je m'étais inscrit
pour faire des études et je suis coincé
j'ai dû arrêter parce que je ne me
sentais pas j'ai pas de mamies j'ai pas
de tati le maire bas parce qu'on vient
d'arriver mon marié militaire donc on
est arrivé l'année dernière donc on est
coincé mes enfants ne pourront pas
retourner à la maternelle lundi parce
que la garderie n'est pas n'est pas ne
sera pas opérationnel parce que la
cantine ne le sera pas non plus donc
c'est un sentiment mitigé aujourd'hui
pour l'instant pour les enfants qui sont
autonomes y aura comme
lundi à partir de lundi par contre les
crèches et les maternelles là où il faut
plus de monde voilà c'est pas évident le
maire et celle à accommoder comme quoi
que avec sia pas d'animatrice que
certains parents se dévoue à venir
surveiller des enfants entre midi et
deux mais tu te fout de la gueule de qui
la propose
alors si l'enfant de la personne affable
problème c'est moi qui suit c'est moi
qui suis responsable
la situation du côté de la ville de
schoelcher reste toujours problématique
après les deux semaines de vacances de
la toussaint
j'attends quelques éléments de plus
supplémentaires pour assurer un service
de cantine
par contre s'agissant des crèches et les
écoles maternelles ce sera peut-être un
peu plus difficile je suis pour ma part
déterminée à faire en sorte que on
arrête de pénaliser les enfants kg
légers étaient suffisamment après irma
après marjah après les contrats aidés en
plus vers la chine cher c'est trop
sont ainsi concernés huit établissements
scolaires soit plus de 1500 enfants